nearly three weeks on there remains one
fact at the heart of this mystery Nicola
bully is still missing but we also now
know much more about the private
difficulties in Nicola's life the issues
with alcohol and her struggles with the
menopause and how she wrestled with them
before her disappearance
in a statement Nicholas family said they
knew police were going to release deeply
personal information
although we know Nikki would not have
wanted this they said there are people
out there speculating and threatening to
sell stories about her this is appalling
and needs to stop the police know the
truth about Nikki and now the public
need to focus on finding her due to the
perimenopause Nikki suffered with
significant side effects such as brain
fog Restless sleep and was taking HRT to
help but this was giving her intense
headaches which caused Nikki to stop
taking the HRT thinking that may have
helped her but only ended up causing
this crisis the public Focus has to be
on finding her and not making up wild
theories about her personal life
it lays better something many will
identify with and tells a fuller story
of Nicola's life than we've heard before
the families say speculation about
Nicola and her partner Paul has become a
distraction
the search operation is continuing the
police theory that Nicola went into the
water on the day she disappeared those
who've assisted with that search say
they should have known about her private
life what if sir changed my my idea
because I've always said from day one
this is so baffling there's somebody a
strange straight mind they might just
wander off somewhere she could be laying
in a ditch she could have wandered into
the woods so that makes them you know a
vulnerable person who don't know where
they are going to go and and that would
have changed our whole search
Lancashire police have referred
themselves to the police Watchdog over a
welfare check they made on Nicola at
home 17 days before she disappeared to
some there have been failures in the
forces communication the police will
have been aware of these issues almost
from day one but the trouble is the
police you see try to control the flow
of information and rather naively here I
think they probably felt that they could
keep this information suppressed
investigation's also been hampered by
the presence of amateur investigators on
the scene a social media influencer who
posted a number of videos of his
searches has been handed a fixed penalty
notice for a public order offense after
being arrested police say they've been
inundated with false information
accusations and rumors that have been a
distraction to their investigation but
their own conduct in that investigation
is now under scrutiny for the family and
friends of Nicola only one thing should
be the priority and that is finding her
she is they said a wonderful daughter
sister partner and mother her two
daughters want a cuddle and they all
just need her home Greg Milam Sky News
said Michael's on wire